depending on where you grow up in the
United States you might hear a different
story about the founding of this country
now I grew up in Pennsylvania and the
story that I heard was about the
pilgrims landing at Plymouth Rock they
were a group of deeply religious people
who had been persecuted in England and
were looking for a new world where they
could practice their religion freely but
many of my friends grew up in Virginia
and the story they heard was about the
founding of Jamestown where a group of
men from England who were adventurers
looking for gold and glory landed in the
new world hoping to make a profit and I
think both of these stories tells us a
little bit about the the founding
mythology of the United States were the
original settlers here looking for
religious freedom or were they here
looking to make a quick buck well in
this video I'd like to take some time to
explore the New England colonies the
story of the people who landed at
Plymouth Rock and then later at Boston
to begin the colony of Massachusetts Bay
and we'll see as we go along just how
different the settlers in Massachusetts
Bay were from those at Jamestown and
also some of the ways in which they were
quite similar now there's no question
about who got here first
as you can see Jamestown was founded in
1607 but it wasn't too much later that
the Pilgrims landed at Plymouth Rock in
1620 and then they were followed by a
much larger group of Puritans who landed
at Boston and founded Massachusetts Bay
in 1630 so let's talk about Puritans so
who or what was a Puritan this is an
image of Cotton Mather he was a
prominent Puritan minister fact the
Mather family will go on to be one of
the great theological families of
Massachusetts Puritans started in
England and their main concern was that
they believed the Church of England
the Anglican Church was too much like
the Catholic Church and this is a fairly
legitimate criticism because in many
ways the Anglican Church was very
similar to the Catholic Church except
that instead of being headed by the Pope
the Church of England was led by the
king
so Puritans hoped that they could purify
the Church of England from its many
Catholic influences so that's where
Puritan comes from purify and by this
they meant that there were too many
rituals too much pomp and circumstance
and not enough focus on the Bible itself
so they kind of wanted to strip away a
lot of the fanciness of the Church of
England in the 1620s the Puritans began
to face more persecution in England now
why did the English government care
about a group of religious folks who
were not big fans of the Church of
England well the answer is that there
was no separation of church and state
and so as the king was the head of the
church if you're casting doubt on the
church you are then casting doubt on the
king and so the Puritans did not make
themselves very popular in England and
sensing that they might be in trouble
many Puritans began to emigrate to the
new world they'd seen lots of tracts
about Virginia and how one could make a
new life there and they thought that
perhaps if they went to Virginia and
they were originally aiming to go to
Virginia they ended up landing a bit
north of there that they could set an
example of what a righteous church and a
righteous society would look like
because they believed that the church
and the Society of England were becoming
much too corrupt
much too divorced from the principles of
the Bible
so in 1620 one group of Puritans set out
for
the New World and landed at Plymouth
Rock and we call them the pilgrims and
then in 1630 a second group set out and
they were just Puritans more broadly and
over the course of the 1630s about
14,000 Puritans emigrated from England
to New England Massachusetts Bay and
what's called the great migration
so what was the difference between these
two groups the Pilgrims and the Puritans
well the pilgrims who arrived in 1620
they were separatists and what that
means is that they thought that the
Church of England was so corrupt that
there was just no chance that they were
going to be able to save it so they
wanted to separate from that church
altogether and live a completely
separate life at Plymouth they had a
pretty small settlement about a hundred
people crossed over on the Mayflower
ship that brought them to the new world
but the group that came over in 1630 the
Puritans they did not want to separate
from the Church of England altogether
they wanted to purify it and they hoped
that by setting an example of a
righteous society they would actually
convince people back in England to adopt
their ways invite them back and that all
of England could become like New England
this man here is John Winthrop and he
was a lawyer who became a leader of the
Puritans he was elected governor pretty
much for his entire life and he wrote
that he wanted Massachusetts Bay to be
like a city upon a hill and be a kind of
a beacon of light showing the world what
a good society could be like now
obviously the New England Puritans did
not get their way they were not invited
back to England to become the model of
English society but they did become the
model of society in Massachusetts Bay
and New England more generally and I
think a strong influence on American
culture writ large so how did life in
New England compare to life in Virginia
well a lot depended on the different
environment of the colony and the
reasons that migrants came to New
England because the environment of New
England was colder the land
was rockier it was both a healthier
place to live because tropical diseases
couldn't flourish there the way that
they could and the marshy areas of
Virginia and was also uh unsuitable
place for large-scale plantation
agriculture so they couldn't grow the
kinds of crops that Virginia grew like
tobacco or even sugar in the West Indies
so that meant that in New England most
of the industry was either family
farming and fishing and also some
trading since they were on the coast and
because most Puritans came over to help
build this city upon a hill they came in
family units not as single men like in
Virginia so there was a much more even
ratio of men to women the families that
came over tended to be well-off enough
to pay their own passage across the
Atlantic tended to be kind of
middle-class artisan types and so New
England didn't have the kind of influx
of indentured servants that Virginia had
nor did it have an influx of enslaved
Africans as laborers because most New
Englanders were farmers and they were
small farmers so they relied on their
own family as labor so a major
consequence of these motivations for
emigrating and this environment was that
New England society was relatively
egalitarian there were very few very
wealthy landowners like there were in
Virginia and very few people who were
completely at the bottom like servants
and enslaved people people who lived in
Virginia had a life expectancy of up to
70 years which was one of the highest
life expectancies in the world at this
time and because reading the Bible was
so
to the Puritans New England also had one
of the highest rates of literacy in the
world at this time but for all of these
positives there were plenty of reasons
why living in New England wasn't so much
fun most of them related to the
strictness of the Congregational Church
Puritans canceled Christmas that they
thought was too much of a pagan ritual
and though you would think that their
own experience of religious intolerance
in England would have led them to be
more tolerant to dissidents that was not
the case
anyone who disagreed with a Puritan
theology or leadership was given the
option to go somewhere else or be
executed for example Roger Williams who
questioned the Puritans actions toward
Native Americans was expelled from
Massachusetts Bay in 1636 and he went on
to found the colony of Rhode Island
where religious dissenters could find a
place of refuge from Massachusetts Bay
just as the people of Massachusetts Bay
had found refuge from England one of
these was a woman named Anne Hutchinson
who in 1637 was expelled from
Massachusetts Bay for daring to be a
woman who preached the Bible so in this
video I've explored some of the
background to Puritans and pilgrims and
aspects of New England society and
religion in the next video we'll
continue our exploration of New
England's life through its politics and
policies toward Native Americans